the director of Life Sciences and
Healthcare here at posit very excited to
bring to you today the ninth installment
of our life sciences series previously
we have highlighted Rose BMS Merck GSK
novarez Johnson Johnson and others and
you can find these positive webinars
linked below and today we have an
exciting webinar featuring the work of
Novo Nordisk we're going to highlight
the journey to an R based FDA submission
and we'll kick off the presentation
today with re the principal statistical
programmer
we'll then pass it over to Stefan
statistician and then we'll end with
Anders statistical specialist
it's such an exciting time for open
source drug development from 2017 to
2020 we had important things that had
happened our and Pharma the r validation
Hub the Pharma verse and then into 2021
we had an R pilot submission to the FDA
and now a little over a year later we
have a full submission NR by Novo and
it's so exciting to see the farmers are
migrating to an open source backbone for
their clinical reporting and what sets
Novo apart is the depth for which
they're tackling this effort the change
management from a multilingual
statistical Computing environment to the
package management and validation and to
the end user support and education for
for example they even have their own
internal R podcast
and all the while contributing to
community efforts like our envirma the
Pharma verse the pilots the missions and
so it's with great joy to bring you this
session today and now I will pass it
over to Ari
thank you Phil we're so excited to be
here and to be able to tell our story of
all the ups and downs we've experienced
in the past few years
before we begin I just have to uh say
that
this presentation represents the view of
the office and not necessarily Norris
and any of the regulatory communication
that we'll show here will not be
applicable to all projects so please
communicate with the appropriate Health
authorities about your submission
without further Ado then earlier this
year we submitted our first R based uh
submission to FDA pmea and other health
authorities around the world
and this happened early 2023 and we have
multiple learnings and feedback from
authorities that we will share later on
in the presentation as well
incidentally this year and Noah Norris
is actually celebrating it's it's a
100th anniversary
and Lenore started in 1923 as Nordic
insulin laboratory and it was at a later
merger with no industry that the current
name in Nova Norris was formed
here in Illinois we focus on treatments
for people living with a series crying
diseases and we have a strong history in
diabetes and now in obesity for which
you may know the company for
statistics where we three said we worked
with the first three steps shown here so
we work with the clinical trials data
and evidence generation and approval
activities
in the evidence that we submit to
authorities we include stdm and Adam
data sets that follow industry standards
such as cdisc we submit programs
documentation analysis tables figures
listings you name it and what we're
going to share today is our story of
getting to do all of this with our
now going back to the beginning
then there's one thing we really really
want to highlight and one thing that
permeates everything in this
presentation
and we put this quote on the slide that
the goal is the transformation process
that is revolutionary in result but
evolutionary in execution
or in other words it's more a matter of
taking steps rather than thinking about
how big those steps should be
now back in 2015 we all joined the
biostatistics in nowhere to an
environment where everything was
dominated by the SAS programming
language
we loved art and we quickly noticed a
huge r-shaped hole at the noble
and to our surprise kids and motion
control systems were also absent and we
were not the first to notice this year
so we got R installed on our local
computers and we used it every now and
then for these one-off non-critical
tasks
in 2017 2016 we started to introduce R
to management and our stakeholders and
colleagues for non-gxp related work
where we were showcasing a shiny as an
incredible powerful framework for uh
um for data visualization that you just
couldn't get anywhere else
we had a shinya for data exploration the
bottom one you see here and one for
assistance in pharmacokinetic and
pharmacodynamic data reviews
we were also using R for crawling SAS
locks comparing stuff and checking stuff
and development of this continued
through 2017 and in 2018
uh we continue to push for adopting some
use of our and the collection of our
programs we're using had grown so much
that we now combined it combined it into
a single package named nnr
and this package was the first thing we
put in inversion control and we also set
up a pipelines for testing it
now come 2019 where we finally saw a
commitment from above to report a trial
in another language that says
so I remember receiving this strategy
email and Stefan was sitting at the desk
right next to mine and I showed him this
and we literally ran into our manager
and said if anybody's going to do this
it has to be us
and and it wouldn't take long until we
got the knob to go ahead with this and
we both thought
like it's real
how do we even do this uh we don't have
a GXP environment for R we don't have a
system for packages I mean we don't even
have a strategy for packages
um so we get down to this and I'll hand
it over to Stefan to tell you more
yes so at this point
we are still using R from our local
laptops without
any system basically at all so we were
in dire need of a statistical Computing
environment
and actually our initial thoughts
regarding this new environment were in
terms of stakeholders
and the change management of those
so we wanted to produce table figures
and listings that were identical to
those that were already produced in SAS
because this mean that there would be no
change for the stakeholders regarding
the language that we would choose it
would also mean that we could use the
existing workflows that we have set up
for producing reports then we're gonna
going to send to authorities
and we could on the same trial work on
both R and SAS
um
we also wanted a system that were
hassle-free for the end user
um so we were trying to cater to our
colleagues
that were used to programming SAS so we
really wanted to show that they didn't
need to think so much about packages
environments as such but more about
getting to the actual programming
so it should also be so that if you've
got a code snippet from your colleague
you should be pretty sure that that
would also work on your computer given
that you were using the same version of
r
and then finally with this new SCE
we really want to highlight Version
Control so remember at this time we
weren't using a Version Control
basically at all uh we had a few things
that we had it on but not for anything
regarding trials so here we wanted to
produce an easy way for initiating a
Version Control for both trial and a
collaboration work such as packages
we quickly saw that these uh four things
would be the pillars of our
infrastructure we really wanted a an IDE
based on our studio workbench or deposit
workbench
because it was such a great IDE and
familiar to so many eye users we did how
I want to make it the server-based
solution so that you would simply log in
to the server and be sure that you were
in common ground with everybody else
then we wanted to use git for our
Version Control
because they were so familiar with most
of the our programmers as we had used it
in the past
um and it will also come with great
features such as feature branching for
our development stuff
we wanted to use Acer devops both
project management so for organizing
tasks but also for all of the code
repositories
democraciados and of course for cicd
pipelines
um
and finally but definitely not least we
wanted to use deposit package manager
for all things regarding our packages
we wanted to use it to share our
internal packages and we also you wanted
to use it for creating subset of
packages that we will call approved
packages for use
now when we started working on this is
CE we were hit pretty hard
by the number of things you need to
consider for making a dxp compliant
system I won't go through all of these
now but it's advisor to say that there
is a lot to think about
um so instead of starting from scratch
we took a look at what do we already
have I mean at the time we were able to
produce all of the stuff that we needed
for the reports that were going to the
to authorities
so instead of starting from scratch we
wanted to piggyback on what we already
had
um so we wanted to launch a computer
next to the one we already had now the
one we already had were located
somewhere in Copenhagen having a files
here with all of the data and output and
such
so we wanted to put it next to it
except we didn't really want to put it
next to it we wanted to put it in the
cloud
because we had no idea how many users
were going to be on the system it would
probably be a few in the beginning and
then a lot as time progressed
um and luckily we got a really really
good Cloud architect to help us out on
this
and together we quickly saw that in
order to fill all of these dxp
requirements we needed full
infrastructures code
and we needed to have Version Control
like on that code so that we could see
who changed what and when
we also rather quickly identified the
need of machine images so for all of our
compute instances that should be built
on a machine image so that we could spin
it up and be sure we would get the same
result the next time as we did before
and finally as we didn't want to do any
manual task we wanted to use a release
pipeline for releasing the entire
infrastructure in different environments
so in 2020 we released our first GXP
um
classified environment for doing a r
stuff
it would look something like this where
a user would come in from the workbench
here that would have access to the
rstudio IDE they could program in R and
they would have access to all of the
packages they would need from the uh
package manager
they could see all of their repositories
and get those from the asset devops
and they could store their code on a
home directory which was a file share in
the cloud
now we still had all of our data
residing on our old computer on the file
share which we located somewhere in
Copenhagen
in terms of features we didn't do much
the first couple of years but we did
make a larger machines let me make more
workbench machines and a load balancer
in front then we made more workbench
machines and still had low balance in
front because of the growing need for
computation in regards to the users
and then come 2022 and we finally
started to introduce new features
we introduced python on the workbench
server and Pi Pi on the positive package
manager we introduced new Ides so that
the programmer would be able to select
the IDE he or she was most comfortable
with us
then we introduced a caching system
and this was because the files here
loaded in Copenhagen had an insanely
slow connection
um to the cloud so this way we would
only have to wait for a data set to be
transferred once and then everybody else
could use the data from the cache
we also released a posit connect
instance
mostly for sharing our markdown
documents and running shiny applications
now this was built on the same image as
the work print machine which meant that
if it worked on the workbench machine it
would almost certainly also work on the
connect instance
when we did have one problem then we're
still remaining here and that were some
users regardless of how big we tried to
make these a workbench machine would hog
up all of the resources that were
available
so in 2023 we finally released a high
performance compute cluster in in the
type of a kubernetes cluster where user
could spin up a darker image
and prove that they will get the entire
IDE but they will be ensured that they
would not step on the toes of anybody
else any other users and speaking of
users
let's just take a look at the user
uptake on this system
so here we have the depicted and the
number of users we have on the y-axis
and the timeline on the x-axis
um and we can see that we didn't have
that many users in the beginning as we
expected uh these users were mainly
those that were assigned to the trials
they were going to produce uh results
that were going to use R for that but if
you can see the time grows we can see
many many many more users
and in the end we're actually not only
supporting the bias statistics
department but also users from other
departments Within numanoidisc
um and I thought we would have had such
a great success in the user uptake on
this system if you didn't have a really
great strategy on handling packages and
now anas will take us through the
handling of these packages from Cran
yeah thank you for that Stephen
so the NM package management really
started in 2020 with the
uh sorry
remember
that we our organization was used to SAS
and SAS only so introducing a new
language that is very much unlike says
that's challenging so says it's nice and
simple
you need to install cess 9.4
it's 10 years old it has been passed a
couple of times but it's still in use ah
on the on the other hand that's not as
simple I is evolving at a higher pace
and I also has all of these packages
in each of these packages they come with
their own versions they come at
different times they have their own life
so these packages are what makes are
Great and Powerful but there is no free
lunch
so dependencies between packages they
quickly become too complex if you just
pick and choose your versions
arbitrarily you need you'll quickly
create a set of packages that does not
work as intended together
so we wanted to create an environment
that is sufficiently fixed and stable
but still flexible and we opted for this
shared Baseline model it has now become
known
so here you log each version of R to a
particular date and time
and you install packages in versions
that were available at that given date
so we do this so that we know that any
pair of dependent packets packages they
were tested at that point in time and
they were tested that they work together
so that means that for example our our
version 4.02 that's locked to some date
in September 2020
that we will always get D player 102.
despite how many ever many releases of
d-plat that has been since so teams
simply just choose their version of r
they can deviate from the standard ones
that we have in the system but if they
do so they must use remb
in general we actually recommend that
you always use RV
so what packages can and should we use
well
they can be roughly categorized in this
way so they are the base and recommended
packages those are the ones that ship
with r they are low risk and they are
very widely used
the contributed ones are the one we need
to do a risk assessment on
so of these there are the widely used
ones they uh they are low risk in by
virtue of the enormous user base
there is the well-tested and documented
ones they may be more Niche but they are
still considered low risk it is the risk
that pose a problem
so when we do a risk assessment we lean
heavily on the our validation hubs
recommendations on how to categorize
so the main points of categorization is
the type of use the maintenance the
popularity and so on so at the end of
the day this is just a human risk
assessment
and the way we prompt this assessment to
get made is by a shiny app
so our users can in the IDE via an
add-in they will be able to select a
request app
and that simply starts up
so in depth they can write what package
they desire and the reason for it and
they can also see which our version and
version of the packets this will be
available in
so when they submit this request it gets
a version controlled in git and gets
shipped it's that kicks off a pipeline
and then risk metrics the risk metric
page tests or performance risk metrics
for the packets in each version of r
that we have and that Associated library
and in all of the environments that we
have on the system
uh manual sorry reviewer can then
manually inspect these results and
arrive at the informed decision
if the reviewer chooses to approve this
then it will get fed to our system code
and then released upon the next release
of that system
so we now have a GXP environment and we
have a strategy for packages but we
still do not have our code for producing
tables figures and listings we do not
have tax execution and login
capabilities in our what about those
this is also handled by the packages
our internal packages and these internal
packages they started as a single
package one package to rule them all in
2019 18.
and this was developed on a local
laptops and it was simply a gathering of
all the usual functions that have been
made
in
2020 we introduced the NN biostat
package that would simply be that was
simply defined as the accepted packages
so users would write library and in BIOS
that can get the most useful packages
in 2021 really realized that nnr had
become too big and it was split into a
packages related to specific tasks so in
another then became just a simple
umbrella of all of these packages like
you know from Thai diverse
so the most important of our internal
imperatives is in an axis that is for
getting data without worrying about
paths or data formats it's in a plot for
creating novel style plots
it's in a table for which defines the
grammar of tables for laying out tables
and creating text based output so we
wanted to mimic what we already did in
SAS
it can also produce HTML outputs we also
have in and Export for exporting table
figures in lists for that fit into our
production Pipeline and we have analog
for patch execution and logging
here we actually use Nita spin to create
nice looking locks
so and although these packages they fit
together in a complicated Network each
package is just like in the real world
it has its own repo it is Menace in an
open source way internally and we have
version numbers a maintainer group we
have pipelines and we have boards for
managing bugs features ideas and much
more
so we aim to follow a common and good
software principles of modularity and we
try to build up functionality like Lego
bricks so we try to segregate the
responsibility of the packages and
Define appropriate extraction levels so
at the bottom here you see the packages
that are close to the system they are
system dependent if you will
and on top you see the packages that are
close to the task at hand
at the top users shouldn't worry about
how the data is stored where is it
stored and so on
they should just concentrate on the task
so for example
a programmer wishes to use an ntfl to
make a mean plot that we'll call in an
axis to fit 8 on data through a
connection set up by Indian remote and
after the plot has been made in an
export will take care of exporting the
data to an appropriate data format and
Associated files that we need
so this has the benefit that we can
change underlying architectures in the
system and simply just do small changes
in the lower level packages if you will
and the users won't see a difference so
this is also the reason that we could
inject a caching system into the system
so let's talk about the tool chain that
we use in Novo
so we use git for Version Control
and Asia pipelines for
executing code upon code changes
we use use this for the description file
in the new file
we use packets down for generating a
website
of documentation and we use our oxygen
to write the documentation
we use lifecycle to convey the stability
or or the life cycle of a function in
within the packages and we use test that
and cover to test the packages
we also use our markdown for writing
longer format documentation in the form
of vignettes
and we use the tools to do the normal
system sorry the normal package
development
so upon the code chains
we will test again the packets in a
matrix way so we test against all our
libraries all our versions of our and
across all of our system
um
environments
so we know that if for example an
upcoming change in development to the
system will will break something in our
packages
we then built the package and then we
release it so in the process of
releasing we are updating the Pakistan
website and we ship it to the internal
repo in the package manager
so we realized some time ago but we
implemented it this year
that we need the ability to deprecate
our versions
so say we no longer want to support the
the oldest version of R we have and stop
then we can then we have made a version
specific repos
so we can stop updating that
this also allows for hot fixes if system
changes are needed
so we try to ensure a high level of code
quality by enforcing a main branch
policy
nobody can change the main brains
directly only pull requests to the main
brains I accept
the pipeline needs to run rig success
and no errors a feature a bug needs to
be linked to the pull request so we know
why we have to change
and we need at least one maintainer to
approve to ensure a code review
so now we both have a system and we both
have the capabilities to execute our
code and I think I'll hand it over to
Stefan so he can show you what it looks
like in the real world
yes thank you so I would like to show
you how a script usually looks uh when
we do it in nominal disk
so all programs we have will start with
the header as I'm showing you now
um this header will include a short
description of
um
what the program is going to do
so in this case we're going to derive
summary statistics for
antibody levels Group by treatment and
gender
we will have a very small outline just
indicating the most important steps of
the program making it easier to read for
another programmer
then the actual code will almost always
start with a call to library in in
biostat this will ensure that we have
the packages that are most most
typically used in trial conduct loaded
into the system and that they are loaded
in the same order for every program
and coming today main part of the code
we will almost always use an axis
because that's how we get access to the
data
we can call in an access on a specific
trial that will give us an a trial
access object
and trial axis object will
have access to all of the trial
connection collections that are
supported for the selected trial in this
case there could be for instance Adam or
sdtm here we're accessing Adam data by
calling db.adam and then we can say what
um what data set we want to to extract
and notice here that we do not have any
paths here that is taken care of by in
an axis and this means we can actually
share this code snippet without thinking
about where it's actually executed it
will always give the same data set
it also allowed us to inject this
caching system so that
every time a user gets a data set that
has already been loaded will simply use
the cache
and about long waiting time
so when having the data we will usually
use a normal d-plier calculations in
order to derive the statistics that we
want to use
so for instance here we will filter the
data
we will
summarize the statistics that we want to
put in the table
and we can in this case group them by
treatment agenda and the parameter code
of Interest
this will give us all of the data points
that we would like to include in our
table
however
now we had this goal
and we wanted to produce tables
um that were identical to those produced
in sets so that we could be used in our
usual
um pipelines for producing reports to
authorities
however we were using this text-based
format
which has it has the tables that would
span multiple pages and we had no
support for that in R so we created our
own package in a table for doing that
now here you can initiate a table rather
easily you simply State what data is
this table going to use and then you can
say
what columns are going to be in this
table you can do some light formatting
saying that we like mean and standard
deviation to be displayed as such
or we would like minimum and maximum to
be displayed with a simple a semicolon
between
this will produce a table looking like
this
um
but we wouldn't be quite happy yet now
normally
we would have all of the summary
statistics nested under each other so we
would have to to make the table a bit
better but you can note that we we have
the display that we we wanted and we
said that we wanted in the call
in order to Nest the summary statistics
underneath the new variable we use the
functionality called add Trend long
where we can say we want these these
columns nested under new column called
sum
um and we can also add some formatting
points and say how many decimals do we
want to apply for the different numbers
that will produce a table like this
which is a bit closer to what we usually
have in our reports however uh you can
see the two new columns down the bottom
the sum and the name column now we would
usually have the sum column nested under
treatment and perhaps uh on the gender
and the type of summary statistics which
is the name column would go under
the parameter code
so we could use this by having these two
added lines of code
where we have ADD transpired where we
can see summary column should be nested
under treatment which again should be
nested under
um gender
similar we can add the stop of the table
saying we want a name nested under the
parameter code
level produce a table like this which
looks like something we've seen before
that we are going to do in adenoma noise
we are able to produce other types of
tables using this so we can export this
via Flex table to print in PowerPoint or
a Word document or directly to HTML
but we are focusing today
on what do we do when we want to export
it to a simple file
and here we use the nnx port
functionality
um from the internet export package
here we can simply say the output name
um
that we want to export and a file name
that we want to export it for
then it will figure out the rest
and then we're actually done with the
with the script that can be used to
produce at the table
and in order to run it we will use a
function called run script that comes
from analog
this function can take both R documents
and our markdown documents and it can
execute those in batch and in parallel
and it will give you some sort of
information about how the execution
actually went
in this case we can see that the
execution actually had an error so let's
inspect that log
as you can see here
we get a nice HTML log
um
and that log is produced via the spin
functionality from the near package
we can see that we have this header up
in the top
that just gives a short description of
how did the execution actually go
then we have the actual description and
the outline that we put in top of our
document and we can see here they are
nicely formatted
after that comes all of the code chunks
that we have
we'll also see all of the outputs in the
log
and in this case we thought we had an
error
um it also highlight both errors and
warnings so that they're very easy to
see as you scroll through the log
and finally in the end of these logs we
always have a an expanded session info
now this session info will include both
um
information about the packages that we
had in the session but also packages
that were simply available at the system
it will also include
options that were set in the environment
and other environment info but that is
actually how we execute scripts and how
we do them in New monorisk in general
but I'll hand it over to anas and anas
will tell us a bit about how we got our
colleagues to actually do this
yeah thank you
yeah so once again
um the way we have primarily been doing
our user support and our education is to
let everybody know that there's help to
to be made so you the help is here
so we have primarily been supporting
people via a One-Stop Shop website that
collects all of these Pakistan sites
um and recently we have a introduced
stack Overflow for teams
as a q a
until then we have been using Microsoft
teams we have been using devops we have
been using plain old mail
to to do the support
in terms of Education we have promoted
self-learning and learning by doing
this has been done through a podcast as
Phil mentioned and
we have internal e-learning as well this
is built on top of degree.com
we also provide lots of external
references and e-learning through the
outside world the ones you can find on
the web
we have done courses and demos on how to
get started with imoval but it's really
the the website that has been doing the
heavy lifting
so the pack the the website looks like
this and we call it the r dark homepage
you simply write our hyphen Doc in the
browser when you're on the corporate
Network and you'll be taking to this
so it's a one point of entry homepage
for everything we had the module that
everything should be here if you cannot
find it here then it should be here and
we will make it
so
this site collects all the documentation
and references just mentioned it has the
podcast it has the Pakistan website it
has vignettes long format documentation
it has an entire output catalog so you
can see uh how a program is structured
it has lots of guides and more
we also link further on to all of these
e-learning and education education sites
something that is that you all know that
is present in our this is not actually a
given in other languages where you can
simply write help
in the IDE and get the documentation so
we of course also convey this to our
users
and we really try to write high quality
documentation on our packages
so you can get this right away we've
also tried to do the equivalent of use
this in a package called in and init and
this will help you get started the first
time you log in it will help you
troubleshoot if you have any any
problems it will help you initialize and
set up stuff trials repos new packages
just in general initiating stuff
and we have also tried to integrate and
utilize all the rstudio features with
add-ins and Snippets to make some nicer
user experience
the podcast is 10 to 15 minutes of how
to's of everything from the complex to
the very simple how do you get started
um
how do you make your first output that
sort of stuff and again anybody can
contribute here
the one thing I want to highlight is
this stack Overflow for teams we have
just recently uh rolled this out it's
only a month old but we can tell already
now that it's
that is going to be really good we have
already 174 questions and 255 sorry not
55 25 answers in the n65 daily active
users
so we really had no good place for Q a
and we wanted to avoid answering the
same questions again and again uh so
this site really helps spread the
support burden
it helps build you a knowledge base and
it's not just for code
and this is also familiar to all
programmers so there's no education for
this needed so if we have any regrets in
terms of change management it is that we
didn't get this out sooner
so now I'll hand it back to Ari and
he'll tell you about the submission
now getting back to what I highlighted
in the beginning
we've always believed in the power of
taking steps rather than thinking about
how big they should be and to put
everything in honest and seven into
perspective and how you could do all
this while doing a drop project we'll
just look at a quick timeline of the
development here
so in 2019 we got the commitment to
report a trial and other language
success
in the beginning of 2020 we had uh
collected functionalities into two R
packages
um soon after that we initiated the
first our program on this trial chosen
to be the first one reported in another
language that says
um
and we even did that before we had the
first workbench in production
unfortunately the trial got delayed but
we were determined to prove that we
could use R in our deliverables and we
did an experiment with delivering a dsur
instead
later on in 2020 we split up the
functionalities and created packages and
package shelf up everything that was to
come
and we were working on the documentation
and released the article home page in
the end of 2020.
and from doing this dsur we just learned
an incredible amount of stuff
um doing our first deliverable so we
updated a lot of core functionalities in
the packages
we update the workbench once more with
the load balancing and multiple servers
uh soon after that I managed to convince
our management that we're now ready to
run a phase three trials in R and we do
the first commits on these trials
immediately after that we follow up with
the five clinical pharmacology trials
and finally uh right before Christmas
and the end of 2021 we report our first
trial ever in another language that says
and between
2022 and 2023 we just have an incredible
amount so first happening
uh and we also update the workbench once
more because we're sending so much data
in and out of it now that it crashes
when we run these big atom programs
so
what we end up with is a huge package of
R based tfl programs and some atom
programs in r
but basically after we proved in the end
of 2020 that it was possible to deliver
a dsur that followed basically all the
same processes internally as we do for
clinical trials we were using R in all
project deliverables from that point on
one thing to note is that we initially
did not intend to submit all of those
rtfl programs if we look at if the a
guidance then our plan was to submit all
of our atom programs uh including those
made in our
and then having those uh rtfl programs
internally and instead submit our assess
parallel programs for our primary and
secondary efficacy analysis which is
something that we've done in projects
before
and that leaves us with this gray area
uh that we were still creating a
strategy for I'll get back to this in
just a second
yeah our programs we submitted they were
designed with a minimal dependencies on
internal packages as we weren't sure how
to best submit packages at this point in
time
we did use our internal package in an
access for getting access to data but we
didn't plan on submitting just as we
didn't submit a SAS based macros that
only work internally
we did still think that we needed to
tell authorities about our views of R so
you can see here an excerpt from a type
c meeting package where we mentioned
that we plan on submitting our programs
and we will specify our related stuff in
the ADHD and submit internal packages if
they are not publicly available
in our pre-pla meeting package we get
more specific and we mentioned that we
intend to use the r package package
slide which packages our packages to txt
uh in order to pass them through the
submission Gateway at the FDA
and this initial approach is the method
used by the our Consortium working group
or for submission in their first pilot
submission to FDA
we also mirror their approach in the
ADHD where we add something about R in
the standard section and we add an
additional very short appendix on what
you would need in order to run the atom
programs
so with this we bundle everything
together and we submit our first
multilingual submission package to FDA
but there's still this gray area that we
need to tackle because we know
the pmda has already made a
pre-submission request for additional
tfl programs and we know that it's not
unusual for FDA or other health
authorities to ask for additional
programs
and lo and behold it doesn't take long
until we receive this
and information request from FDA stating
to facilitate the efficiency of the
safety review submit all programming
codes used to create the tables and
figures in the ISS and the safety
sections of the csrs
and now we're thinking chip
it's real
we really need to figure this out and we
only have 10 days to do it
you can imagine the the stressed looks
on our faces and a lot of deep breaths
that need to be taken at this point in
time
but after we have called called
ourselves down a bit we get to it
so we knew all trials have been executed
with the rnv setup so we could use the
RnB log files to look up versions of all
of the internal packages
we then use a package slide to take
package sources
and repackage them all into a single
packet slide file for each trial
in the submission we now included the
package slide file the rnv log file
packaged to text and modify to use mran
for public packages
we include rnvs activate script that
bootstraps rvnb
and then a script that would unpack
Source packages set up a seller for rnv
rebuild the packages and initialize an R
project with the rnv setup and within a
dedicated folder structure such that all
of the internal Noble packages could run
in the ADHD we update the appendix to
include some information on these new
files that we're submitting and which
commands were needed to restore the
environment and how you could modify the
in an access function
in order to make it run in a local R
project
so we bundle all this together and save
a whole bunch of R based tfl programs
together with the r packages and these
additional files to the FDA
and again I mean at this point in time
we're at on top of the world I mean we
did it now we also submitted packages
and even within this deadline
but
FDA returns again
and they can't get it to work
and now we're really thinking
and together with that message they also
include the following and the
information request
submit our code for all safety analysis
with us minimal package dependency as
possible and no dependencies to our
packages developed internally by known
ordisk
and now we're really thinking
at this point in time we're doubting
everything that you heard up until now
in this presentation the package
strategy the submission strategy uh the
future of R and no notice
report so much energy into making this a
reality and now we're at this pivotal
moment where
I mean we make it or we break it
they can't restore the environment and
they want us to reprogram all the
programs so what do we do
we do something we very very rarely do
we invite FDA for an informal meeting
in the meantime we go back looking at
our build script and optimize it once
more
we also optimize
the RV log file to use a password's
public package manager as at this point
in time Imran has now shut down
we write a very long and very detailed
instruction with screenshots of
everything that's happening and what you
should expect to see when you're
restoring the environment when you're
executing uh different parts of the
scripts and we shift this off to FDA
before the meeting hoping that we now
have done it right
this meeting happened quite recently and
minutes before the meeting we are quite
nervous
like what are they going to say are we
going to be grilled
and the meeting starts and it turns out
they now have been successful in
restoring the environment and we were
just thinking yes
and they bring out the programs and
mention that part of the reason for them
asking
is that it gives FDA an opportunity to
see how code inside and outside of
packages are built and this would be a
great learning opportunity for FDA
the statistical reviews in the meeting
with FDA are just so super nice and we
realized one very important thing from
this meeting
submissions in R is new to us but it's
definitely new to FDA as well
this brings us to the Future where we
have three main points that we want to
dive deeper into we want to have a
stronger our dedication we want
improvements to recreating environments
outside of the NN malls and we want to
fully embrace the open source
as part of the audit education we have
multiple fully art-based projects are
already started and now also dedicated
teams to support our package and system
development
we have learned some very valuable
environment lessons around the
rebuilding cross-operating systems and
the fact that the official positive
package manager stored binaries of
packages was really invaluable in this
submission as we didn't need to compile
from a source on Windows machines
and we already have many ideas for how
we can work just around this into our
workflows and also guide colleagues and
peers for regulatory interaction
and last but not least
fully Embrace open source
the cleanup of all of our Intel packages
will start soon and we will move towards
open development on GitHub
we will rebuild a lot of our core
functionalities such that it will work
for the broader programming community
and aim to get our packages onto Quran
and dive much deeper into farmers
before we end I really want to
acknowledge
all the packets contributors and systems
and contributors that we have the
programmers and statisticians that
fought to learn are on these trials
through at a very hectic time the
invaluable input and knowledge coming
from our peers at other companies
working with our working groups under
our Consortium the r validation Hub and
all the efforts going into making
something like this possible
we would also like to acknowledge the
fact that FDA agreed to meet with us and
advertise in the end of the day it's
also just nice normal people working at
FDA
they are much more open and welcoming or
far than we anticipated
and we encourage that you reach out just
as we did so thank you so much for
listening to our presentation
awesome thank you Novo team that was
fantastic gosh what a what an aid this
is going to be for other pharmas going
down this path
um we have more questions than I think
we have time for so we're going to
tackle a few of them and they also came
in at different times before you had got
to that point later on in the
presentation so if you think we've
already tackled it just let me know but
I'm going to go based off of popularity
and we've got 30 plus questions so let's
tackle a few of them
um and so let's start off with this
first one
um how can we ensure that our code
including internal R packages is
responsible it's reproducible on a
reviewer's machine such as that of the
FDA
yeah yeah yeah
yes so so that is a good question and of
course we cannot completely ensure it
um what we can ensure is that we can
reproduce the environment so that they
have the same packages available the
same version of R available that they
in that way they we can make sure that
they have data in the places we would
like them to have data in and that way
use our programs and that was what we
did in the scripts that we sent to them
now was to to actually
from the file that we have submitted in
this M5 folder structure make it
possible to recreate
um the entire folder structure that we
normally work upon
and then reuse the in and access
facility and an unbiased functionality
to ensure that the packages that they
have loaded is the same
um as what we are seeing
um and and thereby
be very close to the fact that they will
get the same results as us as close as
we can get
fantastic anybody else on the Nova team
want to mention
comment
no I think that's yeah
all right so let's go to another
question here so
um the next question says how long
before it becomes a common practice in
Novo to use R for trial related
programming
so I think well so I mean I think uh
doing this one uh drug project at first
has really kind of kicked off uh like an
internal Revolution for for doing this
because we proved that it was possible
to do it uh it's been hard and difficult
and there's a lot of change management
involved but the benefits we've seen
from this are like reusing tfl objects
into result meeting slides like all the
benefits we get from doing HTML based
stuff now is just spilling over into to
other projects I think uh probably we're
closing in on maybe 30 40 of the trials
now are starting up in in R
um and we have
I think
115 trials ongoing currently
um so the uptake is is quite big
yeah
fantastic any other comments
let's jump to the next one all right so
the next one is about the scope of the
undertaking how many personnel are
needed to maintain the complexity of
this environment
will you take that step
um yeah so that's a hot question also
because there's really been a bottom-up
adventure where we you saw from the the
top that we would like us to make this
report of trial in another language to
Nar
um
and then we were pretty much allowed to
run with it
um
so we've been a few people working on
the packages I would guess six that
would do usual commits
we have been mainly three to work on the
statistical Computing environment
um in terms of the actual development of
it we had way more in terms of getting a
dxp validated
um because there yeah that's just a much
much bigger Adventure but in terms of
active development
um
yeah and then how many for actual
tracker my actual trial conduct I mean
there's been a very steep learning curve
on the trial so
I would say there's anything between
um yeah 30 40 50 programs and
statisticians that I've been running all
of these trials uh creating our programs
uh I must say all the trials have been
running in parallel which has also made
the workload uh quite a lot bigger but a
lot of people have been involved in
doing actual trial conduct
yeah
yeah and and one thing I think we need
to add is also that we get you know as
we do it internally open source lots of
people step up and contribute for the
the podcast for example is you know
somebody came up with that and we said
go with it let's put it on this ardox
thing the same with this degree another
guy came up with that and so we just
grabbed those balls and we really try to
encourage
our users and our friends to to to to to
that to do that sort of thing so it's um
so it's hard to put in terms of ftes uh
because we can't really can't we don't
know actually yes
and and on that point that's about been
learning for for us to have been
developing the packages first to to
actually start to let go and let the
community and be the main drivers so for
instance for this table package that we
have we're getting more and more
contributors around the company for
features that they would like it to to
include and also feature requests of
course as why can't I use the DT package
directly from this so we will of course
start to implement that uh so that it
has full support for that as well yeah
fantastic so
I've got a couple more questions so I'm
let's
um I'm gonna go a little bit faster on
these just because we uh we've got a lot
of people still on so let's keep going
so this next one uh said what can you
clarify by what you mean by first R
based submission
it says are all the programs in code
were in r
yeah so all of the tables figures and
listings that we've made have all been
in r
so uh at Novo we have been using
um a data set for analysis results for
quite some time meaning that the
statistical analysis are still done in
SAS put into a huge data set and then
report it through our tfl programs so
statistical analysis are still onto the
side onto and into SAS
but everything else in regards to tfl
happen developed in r
and then as well we have some of these
uh
R based atom programs which have
primarily been for the data set where we
just need the additional compute power
that we can get from being in the cloud
because they have been extremely huge
awesome another question what were the
business benefits of an R solution you
know relative to commercials or
uh for example SAS
it's a good question
um
I guess so like Stefan said this spills
over or if you believe it's UI and it
spills over in all sorts of other things
so when we do presentation slides or we
do other stuff uh it's much more easy to
pick up and do something more powerful
with these
um shiny apps and so on they also can
utilize the packages so we can kind of
again build up functionality
so it really spills over but it's again
it's impossible to say like in terms of
uh money how much again it is but we see
it kind of starting to permeate into
other non-gxp tasks and and other stuff
that we do
and one other very important aspect from
the from the business side have been how
do we get more employees enrolled in
biostatistics because we are doing more
and more trials so we need more and more
employees
um
and here we have seen that there are
just so many more uh people we can get
who know are than there are actually
people coming out who know SAS so from a
business benefits obviously one of the
highest
values is getting new employees and
getting them up to speed fast yeah
definitely
so you just mentioned research and other
areas
um and for the late stage here a
question that comes up I think a lot of
people are wondering about is do you
plan to use python in a submission too
and does your scientific or or
statistical Computing environment
support Python and our development and
apps
yeah
we have python on the system it is a an
experimental feature if you will so and
as far as I know we don't have any plans
for doing submit python-based
submissions but we feel that there is a
pressure so the users or some users
really want that as well so now we are
trying to come up with similar
strategies for handling python so that
so you can really have a true
multilingual system
but we have seen we have started the
process but it is a bit harder with
python than our because we don't have
um crane
um where we have a much much better
control
and we know that the packages are tested
together so we can have this a nice
strategy for how we put the packages in
where we know that these packages are
going to function together that doesn't
really apply to python so
that is at least a
the problem that we're tackling right
now in order to do it
awesome how about one more question here
um how often do you update your
different R environments
yes so um we've been
doing I guess if you even them out it
would be like a half yearly update
um
but it has depended on on how big are
the features that we're working on uh
quite recently we had a a large gap
between them because we were working on
this kubernetes cluster so I have a sort
of a big thing and we needed to develop
the kubernetes cluster and also uh get
it dxp approved before we could release
it to the broader community and so there
we had I think almost a year but usually
it would be about every half yearly and
then we have a commitment both in terms
of user request but also
for ourselves then we really want to go
down to every second month to to have
updates of the system
um so that new packages can get to users
much much faster than they do now
and also I mean if we're diving more
into open source where the release cycle
at least from the stuff we see in Farmer
versus is quite fast like we need to be
up to speed if we want to include like
the latest updates into our trials as
well so
we really want to get the release cycle
down yeah exactly
one thing though
um
even though we have a rather strict
package management strategy we have made
it so that all users can actually if
they work a little bit for it not much
but just change the repository the
options repost argument then they can
lock themselves into a newer version of
the packages and start working from
there and so it is possible and we do
have some projects that are starting to
do that if they feel that the system has
fallen a bit too much behind that we
need to work with the newer packages
available then we have shown them okay
how can you do that yourself and still
ensure that you are compliant
so my team just mentioned that we still
have a lot of people on so if you have
some time let's keep going what the heck
right the questions keep flooding in
um how about this one I I like this so
for your next R based submission uh what
are some things you might do differently
that jump out to you
I think one thing is
um I mean we realize now that
uh statistical reviewer of at FDA or on
other health authorities might not have
adequate time to uh kind of get
acquainted with a whole set of packages
that's being submitted
uh meaning that if you're building like
super smart functionality and a lot of
packages and they all like really work
well together uh getting that kind of
thrown in the face as a reviewer might
be too much and you wouldn't have time
to dive deeper into it
so we're thinking of a lot of ways of
how do we expose like the derivations
the calculations the analysis that we're
doing in programs either through like
better locks or kind of surfacing more
of like the Deep based derivations that
we're doing
um and then uh I mean we want to do a
submission with Admiral as well we want
to use more of these Farm reverse
packages in them
um
and definitely as I mentioned here uh
testing in Windows based operating
system is something we will definitely
be building into kind of our submission
pipeline that this it is something that
just needs to work
um
so yeah
fantastic all right how about two more
and uh then I officially will uh we'll
end the webinar for today so how about
given the significant overlap between
the responsibilities and functions of it
and biostats how was collaboration
between these two
sectors facilitated
um
there is actually a good example of this
we
at the very first time
um EIT development sort of developed an
R server without so much response from
biostatistics
um and in that server we said you can go
here and you can start programming and
the first thing I tried was okay so I
want to install titles so that I could
get going you know that won't work here
we don't have all of these things
installed in the system so that you can
actually do that
and okay okay so so I can't even use
tidy boost this is going to be an
yeah that's deep Steve climb if we're
going to use base R for everything
um
so so from that day we started a really
really close collaboration because we
sort of saw the need that even though
you know
everything about it and you might not
know all the needs and that there are
for an R based system
um so from there we would have both our
developers and it developers working
closely together ensuring that
we would yeah have the best system
possible for the end user
um yeah
okay last question this is it I promise
how about
you know one thing we hear a lot about
our other Regulatory Agencies besides
the FDA for submissions so someone says
can you share about your experience with
our submissions outside of the FDA EMA
pmda Etc
yeah so I really want to bring up an
example from the the r Consortium
working group are for submission where
we also try to reach out to pmda uh
through some of our
PS in the Japanese Pharmaceuticals
manufacturing association jpma and the
message we got back from uh from pmda
was that that they didn't feel a need
for a pilot submission because they
already accepted our submissions
um and what we we have still included in
in our
correspondences with the pmda for
instance that we're using R for
different stuff we've giving them flow
charts of stuff and with pmda we even
um suggested that we would submit RDS
files instead of xpt files just because
we had these huge data sets that were
more than 250 gigabytes in xpt which uh
I think any local laptop would be
it will be difficult to open those up
so and they've been very open
um and I would say
from all the health authorities that we
have talked with none of them are
questioning the use of or they are still
coming with the same scientific
questions about the submission of course
here we got some technical questions
about restoring the environment but it
was it was because they wanted to make
it work
um so only positive things I would say
well fantastic thank you again I think
this has been one heck of a webinar and
the community is going to really enjoy
watching this afterwards I suspect we
also can tackle some of these other
questions maybe in a blog post so thank
you so much Ari Stefan Anders truly
wonderful to hear about your experience
the journey went down and and the
collaboration with the community and
internally has been fantastic so with
that we do thank you one last time and
thank you to the community that's turned
out for the webinar today and stay tuned
we'll be posting this on line here soon
for those of you that may have missed
some parts and hopefully we see you at R
and Pharma coming up in October and with
that we'll bid everybody for well and
have a wonderful afternoon thank you
everybody